let me ask you this when you tweeted
that
he's more a tool for white supremacy or
a puppet rather because it matters then
lgbtq
what do you mean by that he's a [ __ ]
entertainment piece for mainstream
america like puppets he's the show when
you say white supremacy yeah because at
the highest level of people looking
right at the why is the premier this is
the top level in this country right who
knows if people are embarrassed who
knows of everything he's their
entertainment piece
for me like you said he's a one-of-one
right and he and he know everybody that
looked like me is shrinking down in
their seats like oh man and it's not
everybody is not just cause you're gay
it's just your shit's corny sometimes
again man when you black it's not fair
right it's not fair but there's things
expected of you and i'm not demanding
more than you then i wouldn't demand
from prince or any other great artist
you feel me you don't get off cause you
gay
you don't get off cause you you still
expected well guess what [ __ ] you gotta
carry two torches
don't make us look stupid like you don't
make them people look stupid
feel me so i think he's doing a bad job
of making people look yeah i mean he's
just
doing it goofy like you're not really
adding to the culture you're not
creating a trend of things that's gonna
happen you gotta dig deep
bro you went through some real struggles
if you're a young black gay man you went
through some real struggle for sure can
i get that of course can i stop getting
these generic records that are not like
you're making bad versions he's making
pop records he's not making anything
with substance or depth to them as far
as like him talking about like
really tapping into the struggle gotta
at least be backstreet's back is good
i mean that i mean look he got one he
got the little uh the old town road is
is that fire i mean you know
but now but like damn we like eight or
nine then we had about four like come on
that's what i said i never heard a whack
little nazak song
i never heard no i'm whack no no he's
he's too good to make a wax on at this
point like he's a good artist like he
makes records i'm not saying he's made
anything better than old town road